according to the 2017 Verizon data
breach investigations report 90% of all
incidents and breaches that involve
social actions by external actors
include fishing everyone is overwhelmed
with email and it just takes one person
to hardly click on a rogue message to
have a fishing incident if you've ever
seen an email that looks like this
you'll know what I'm talking about
our first defense is to prevent phishing
emails from ever reaching people
Gmail filtering blocks the majority of
malicious email and our global
visibility across users makes this
visibility highly effective Gmail also
restricts the use of file types that
carry a high potential for security
risks even inside a compressed file if a
malicious link gets through the next
layer of protection is Safe Browsing in
Chrome which prevents users from
visiting known phishing websites where
their credentials can be stolen or
malware installed on their device then
even if an attacker manages to gain the
credentials they were looking for such
as a user name and password we provide
two-factor verification and security
keys which make the use of compromised
credentials extremely difficult instead
of entering a unique code as a second
factor at sign-in security key sends us
cryptographic proof that users on a
legitimate Google site and that they
have their security keys with them a
physical action is required and since
most hijackers are remote their efforts
can be thwarted because they cannot get
possession of the security key to
increase control further businesses can
take advantage of security key
enforcement which allows Google Cloud
administrators to enable 2-step
verification that forces users to use
security keys as the second factor
security keys work with Google accounts
at no charge but you'll need to buy a
compatible USB device directly from a
u2f participating vendor finally if a
Chromebook somehow gets compromised as a
result of a phishing attack it can
quickly and easily be restored to a
known good State to find out more about
how Google cloud can help protect you
from major cyber threats contact us at
google.com slash cloud slash security